d'une salle de spectacle à une autre
d'une ville à une autre on quitte lui en
cours au parcours bois d'arcy
le premier spectacle est un rendez vous
musical et ensoleillé ça sera donc à la
grange de la slap où je vais y arriver
par dans la grange de trembler avec à
bois d'arcy a dit revenu en cours au
décidément bien changé de vie commune et
rendez vous musical vallat ensoleillé
avec yvan le bolloc'h et le groupe ma
guitare s'appelle reviens c'est un
spectacle entre humour et musique yvan
le bolloc'h son tour sur celle d'un
d'une troupe toute une équipe de gitans
d'espagnol de maghrébins et une femme
une seule elle est hollandaise et ça
fonctionne très bien on va regarder un
court extrait du dernier dans des clips
ni café oui
micah p mick harvey en l'air
en dix ans les anglais au lait
mais oui
à
la partie
on les enlever le
voilà pour ce texte l'ademe café
motivant le bolloc'h avoit d'arcy à la
grange de la tramblais ce samedi le 13
octobre à 20h30 pour ouvrir la saison et
je vous propose tout de suite justement
de découvrir les coups de coeur d'eric
fauveau qui est le responsable de la
programmation de la salle et voilà ça va
être père costa qui ne compagnie
irlandaise qui entrent au stop et les
paillettes en gros du bronx qu'un
spectacle assez hallucinant de
percussions à la fois des tambours
japonais et des petits yeux pleins de
sable donc c'est un vrai spectacle
drôles étonnants
ancien possible que j'aie une
particulière attention au cirque moderne
ça contemporain une compagnie belge qui
s'appelle e à o'keefe un steak c'est pas
le mètre carré qui a parlé d'un
spectacle assez c'est un rat comptable
c'est inexplicable c'est une expérience
à vivre
voilà pour ces quelques coups de coeur
est ce qu'il y aura des têtes d'affiché
aussi cette saison alors on a vu yvan le
bolloc'h il y aura également guy bedos
ou encore charles berling qu'on n'attend
pas forcément le conte trouvera la
chanson alors les accents pédagogie
continue au sein du de la grange à
trembler avec par exemple les jumeaux
vénitien ça sera une première mondiale
c'est un spectacle joué par la troupe
versaillaise viva la commedia et mise en
scène y puise en scène par don par
anthony magnier
ça sera samedi 20 octobre à 20h30
une rencontre d'ailleurs est prévue avec
le metteur en scène avant le spectacle
et la salle de spectacle qui travaille
en partenariat avec la médiathèque tous
les organismes culturels de la ville
participent voilà spécialement ces deux
structures et qui travaille ensemble on
va justement écouter la responsable de
la médiathèque
isabelle rose jalabert dans cette grange
merveilleuse et une salle qui s'appelle
le grenier au premier étage une très
jolie salle sous les poutres qui est
principalement dédié à toutes les
animations jeunesse de la médiathèque
c'est à dire l'heure du conte
une fois par mois un club signer une
fois par mois également une animation
pour les tout petits qui s'appelle
croquelivres qui est fait en partenariat
avec les services de la petite enfance
la boîte à meaux en fait
l'idée c'est de proposer des lectures
spectacles qui donne envie
éventuellement d'aller relire ou d'aller
découvrir des auteurs voilà qu'on n'a
pas forcément l'habitude d'entendre
et puis toujours dans un esprit de
convivialité voilà à la fin de chaque
boîte a beau on discute on échange
autour d'un verre nous avons parlé sur
cette chronique culture de la saison
culturelle du côté de guyancourt
également de bois d'arcy est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres idées de sorties bon changer
trois propositions toujours des idées de
sorties à maurepas tout d'abord à
l'espace albert camus est bien la salle
accueille le chorégraphe la chorégraphe
pardon carolyn carlson qui est d'origine
californienne
elle viendra donc présenter son
spectacle qui donne ces samedi soir le
13 octobre à 20h45 pour les amateurs de
48 si vous voulez danser bien
association quentin khan tué line dance
organise un bal dimanche après midi dès
14 heures 30
ateras pouvoir quelques images
d'ailleurs ça va nous donner envie de
danser wilfrid je suis sûr je sens tout
le monde dansait sur mathieu deux
inscriptions sont obligatoires tous les
renseignements disponibles sur leur site
internet qui est très bien fait très
complet s'il ya de l'ambiance en plus en
vie au vu des dernières ce titre info ça
se passe à plaisir au théâtre espace
coluche qui vient de lancer une
application pour smartphone intitulé
théâtre espace coluche ça c'est leur
nouveauté pour cette rentrée
et puis et bien vous pourrez avec cette
application tout connaître de la
programmation programmation d'ailleurs
ce week-end avec la comédie musicale
hair à 21h voilà pour ce programme
complet votre chronique culture jouanin
retrouvent mercredi prochain mêmes
horaires en direct aux alentours de
18h30
on va continuer à parler culture avec de
nouveaux invités bande dessinée plus
précisément avec le festival de buts 19e
édition juste le temps de vous écouter
aux sorties des salles ce matin c'est la
rubrique vos sorties ciné vous nous
donner vos avis sur les nouveaux films à
l'affiché aujourd'hui on a été voir
clochette très bien les enfants sont
bien
on s'en contente donc impeccable alors
franchement très bon film c'était bien
il y avait des serbes y en avait eu
neige il y en avait et neige en été la
chaleur l'a fait que j'ai décidé bien
ils ont beaucoup aimé et monfils qui
habituellement ne tient pas une heure et
demie au cinéma là il m'a dit que
c'était trop court et que ça durait pas
assez longtemps
c'est un beau film ans mauvaise image
côté féérique de disney très bien il
était trop beau et puissant corpiq ça et
ouais c'était bien la fée clochette
c'était très bien belle histoire les
enfants sont contents
je suis allé voir ted avec ton venin
kunis et inventeur que je ne connais pas
et main fosse était divertissant et oui
j'ai patiemment un agréablement je vais
voir état des lieux très drôle à il
était vachement marrant en fait super
hilarant il ya de bonnes vannes
bon il y avait nos côtés histoire
d'amour auquel il fallait s'y attendre
mais c'était bien c'était vraiment un
film intéressant